you're going to be absolutely disgusted
when you hear how evil this company is
see not too long ago people cooked with
real animal fats in the form of lard so
this company thought why not replace
expensive lard with cheap cottonseed oil
a super toxic oil originally used for
lubricating machines we could give it a
nice sounding name like vegetable oil
has a healthy ring to it right one
clever marketing campaign later and boom
pretty much everyone was using Dirt
Cheap vegetable oil to cook their meals
later they found out that the fat and
vegetable oil turns into a varnish-like
substance in your body causing cancer
heart disease and all kinds of nasty
things but who cares when you can make
billions of dollars in profits what
started out as an industrial lubricant
is now in tons of food you eat every
single day and what company is
responsible for all of this click the
link in the pinned comment to watch the
full video and find out